I've been on the keto diet for a month
or six weeks and and let me here let me
just before I tell you about the plane
let me tell you about the keto diet for
I forget here's some of my findings so
the no sugar right you got to stick to
the keto diet and I had there were a
couple times where I had some chocolate
that was only like 60% cacao or whatever
and you're supposed to be at like 75%
but but anyway here's what I found from
that diet is you lose a lot of weight I
found I lost a lot of weight by staying
off of anything processed and off of
sugar like I got lean like lean to where
I had I didn't know I could be as lean
like I lean in my muscle really like I
could see things that I've just memories
in my like I started remembering [__]
like my brain got lean like it took the
gristle right off my brain and and
suddenly I remembered maybe a gift that
someone had got me a long time ago or I
remembered somebody who maybe it held a
door for me maybe you know seven or
eleven years ago at a 7-eleven maybe
even but it was it was interesting
because it just took the it took a lot
of the fog out of me I noticed mentally
so mentally from being on the keto diet
a lot of the fog was lifted I felt more
energy more free energy because I'm
always thinking oh I gotta have these
carbohydrates and this and that
and I'm not saying go do the diet I'm
saying look there's some downsides of it
I'll tell you in a second but I just
want to make sure that I let you know
the experience that I had from a month
on the keto diet and the sugar you know
I definitely noticed him withdrawals man
you want [__] sugar boy what is that
a sugar what is that do you get if
somebody whistles for a tax he bro you
[__] and they've been having a
doughnut or a snack or
you know uh something recently you even
in the do you hear somebody whistle and
you [__] what is that Oh sugar lips
over there they had a sucker two weeks
ago at the bank you can hear it on their
lips
you know you get real caught into you
can you get jealous of it somebody you
see somebody leaving the store with a
bag of bread and you you follow them to
their car you don't even realize it
you followed them to their car what am i
you kind of come out of a trance what
are you gonna do you're gonna change
you're gonna choke somebody out for a
loaf what are you gonna do you know so
you get really doing some withdrawals I
got angry I noticed I get real spicy a
real real real spicy with others I mean
somebody said something I don't like it
and I'll tell you I don't you know I
just make a face like mmm you know like
somebody just been stuffing mouth just
been just hiding a bunch of very very
very young lemons in my [__] mouth
mmm I make a face like that
mmm boy mmm
so you got you you know if you if you're
one of the Seven Dwarfs you grumpy
that's how it made me it made me you
know I had some withdrawals but it made
me very alert it made me when I woke up
in the morning I felt immediate energy
and excitement I don't have to wake up
it was like I was either asleep or I was
awake and there wasn't a lot of like
shifting gears in between the two I was
ready to go
you know I felt like I started to feel
like a lot of foods and stuff really
slow me down really slow you down it's
almost like what you eat it's like if
you have a lot of bread and you you get
bread it up you know you might feel a
you know it's like you're a little
slower in the morning you got a couple
of baguettes in your step you know you
got a couple of uh you're on the
basketball court you're a little slow or
you got a couple of croissants stuck in
your crossover you know you know you
start
feel like I start to notice whatever I
eat is wet that is it impacts my
behavior or it impacts my emotion my
fluidity or fluidity so I started to
notice that a hundred percent you know
you might have a couple you know a
little bit slower on the dance floor if
I've been having too much dessert it
kind of sticks to you you know I have a
couple of creme brulees in my hip hop
array you know oh hey
ho so I noticed that kind of stuff I hit
you know I maybe have a little bit more
you know I might have a couple wall you
know I might have some I just have a
little bit less I'm less fluid I'm kind
of slowed down and and so those are some
things that I noticed on the kiito's
diet some withdrawals from the sugar
much better energy much better mental
clarity very very clear anger more anger
now at the same time I was on chantix
non-cigarette pills and I mean people
you that the anger the anger could have
been from the pills you [__] kill you
know you'll drive a car into a [__]
shopping mall during a during a Nike
sale you know during a sale over there
at all Estee Lauder's so it's that kind
of vibe you know
so chantix is you know the non-cigarette
pills they'll make you do [__] so I
shouldn't have been crossed I was cross
pollinating the different evacuations I
was trying to evacuate the sugar and the
bread and the coquitos diet and I was
also trying to evacuate nicotine so I
think I spoiled you know I spoiled the
you know I spoiled myself as a testing
facility but but those are some things
that I did notice immediately my mental
clarity
which was very clear but I was very
antsy and some of that could have been
just still withdrawals from the sugar
and I probably should have taken a
little bit more time but I think I'm
gonna die I'm going to do it again I'm
just gonna I'm going to make sure that
I'm not doing something else at the same
time like not mixing diets are not
trying to evacuate you no sugar and
cigarettes and you know alcohol or
whatever else all at the same time just
because at all that's a lot but that was
the keto so less body gas more clarity
movement I would move a lot faster
quicker much clearer to communicate
anger though I found myself getting
angsty I didn't notice any drop offs of
my energy levels I noticed a lot of lean
lean body lean what else people say you
get keto crops or something or keto
crotch I didn't get it
my crotch seemed normal my crotch has
enough issues as is you know with that
mild - you know kind of lower case
erectile dysfunction Matt you know my
you know my dick it's not I don't ever
write my dick is lazy though I will say
that I got that LD and you know I'm
saying if you walked in it you know say
you walked in a work and a lot of dicks
are supposed to be at their desk you
know doing the typewriter my dick would
be over there about a wall you know
maybe having a cigarette or sir or lying
on one of his coworkers you know trying
to fly so those are some things that I
notice I'm trying to think of anything
else so I get real clear on what my
experience was doing the keto so does
she have just nothing anybody's I asked
him but I do get you know messages
saying hey what you know what's going on
so and oh I started to notice
immediately after about four days five
days I started to notice
some sugar and some sugar candies were
just too much man
like once I started to lose the palette
for like a snicker or even you know you
know uh whatchamacallit or uh some Necco
wafers once you started to lose that
palette man when you looked at him again
you were like oh that looks nasty then
you know me I love a baby snicker dude
if I go to heaven you know when the Lord
lifts his skirt up I hope I hold you
know I hope about thirty baby Snickers
falls right out of his dress and and so
when I you know when I started to look
at these candies and it was just too
much for me I just it was you know it
was surprising I was like wow I now I
see eight where that sugar is and it
makes me I don't want anything that
sugary it's too much it felt fake and
natural sugars I started to really like
the taste of like 80% cacao chocolate
the [__] that you taste you're like damn
this ain't chocolate at first but by the
seventh day on keto you're like dang
that stuff is sweet you start to really
realize where sugar is everywhere
they'll put sugar on your [__] wife
bra if they think you don't like her and
a lot of women use sugar they know we
you know you'll see a lady show hot a
couple of uh you know a couple of Milk
Duds or something on the back of her
neck she'll take a [__] uh uh tape a
you know a little short stack of
starbursts on the nape of her neck
because they know sugar attracts men
you'll see a lady back in a day she'll
put her head on the side and put a
couple drops of um of honey in her ear
that old-fashioned [__] keep you
around sauce you know because they know
this sugar attracts so but that was my
experience man that was my experience
and even I noticed like a tomato for
we're really good if we
tastes really sweet and that was about a
sugary as I got cuz you gotta stay off
fruit as well
there was from couple moments where I
cheated like it would be you know I
would have like a sunflower seeds and
like a banana or something at night a
couple times and that's just my
experience I hope to have a bigger and
more lengthly experience but that's been
my experience so far that I tried well
thanks for watching that video right
there that was a beautiful little
segment I think but of course i'm
partisan to myself but you can move on
to another video right now you can check
on this video or on this video that's
two different options and you can also
subscribe to the channel check on a new
video subscribe to the channel check
subscribe subscribe